if you look out the top this is what a
cicada looks like when it's coming out
of the ground
yeah so you got you got artwork over
here as well
are you ready cheers actually i'm less
scared of this okay
oh the crunch do you have a wing hanging
out of my mouth
[Music]
cicadas shouldn't cnn be eating crow
[Music]
all right you know what it's time for
hey kids it's time for democrat corner
[Applause]
[Music]
yes welcome to democrat corner we're
your host greg gutfeld that's me
gives a quick lesson in basic things to
help democrats stop ruining your lives
tonight's very special episode cause and
effect
so you're probably wondering what is
cause and effect i'm a democrat
simply put simply put democrat it's when
one thing
makes another thing happen for example
when cat drinks too much tequila here we
go
she doesn't go to work the next day
that's cause and effect
then she stays home and watches forensic
files all day which makes her depressed
cause and effect then she starts abusing
horse tranquilizers
cause and effect which is how i sold
all those horse tranquilizers cause and
amazing effects
see cause and effect can lead to bad
things if you don't consider the
consequences of your actions
for example if you remove consequences
to criminal acts
criminals will commit more crime but if
you punish crime
crime will go away because cause and
effect
so you probably saw this horrible attack
at nyc
it's one of many this insaniac who
punched her
had been arrested 17 times but bail
reform today means no bail and no
jail it's catch and release with fiends
instead of fish
the upside the prisons aren't
overcrowded the downside
chinatown emergency rooms are that's
cause and effect
now cause and effect example two mayor
de blasio cut
90 plus million dollars that was meant
to build a new police precinct
because police are bad scream the media
even the ones that guard their studios
but in the last five months nyc has had
531 shootings up from 295 in the same
time frame i do the math
but i'm too important for that so now
the mayor is reinstating the
the money for the pr precinct we could
have told him that would happen
we actually did but apparently we were
drowned out by the voices in his lumpy
googly-eyed head
cause and effect example three baltimore
mayor brandon scott once pushed to cut
the police budget by 22 million
now he's proposing a 27 million dollar
increase wonder why
homicides are up 17 percent cause and
effect
defunding reduced the police force and
more people died probably minorities
but to libs addition and subtraction is
harder than calculus
so as crime increased and law
enforcement was vilified what did we
predict
example four more first-time gun gun
buyers
me included ironically democrat mayors
are causing gun sales to increase
the new york times just admitted this
roughly one-fifth of all gun purchasers
last year were first-timers and it ate
old white boys like me
nope half were women a fifth were black
and a fifth were hispanic
and they were younger and trying to take
those guns increases the likelihood
they'll vote republican
i do love that half the new purchases
were from women now that's an accessory
it beats a fitness tracker the highest
concern for purchase though was personal
safety
apparently guns are the new seat belts
in 2021
and fewer people said it's for sports
and recreation
today that's like calling my purse a
messenger bag
see after the politicians and media
decided to make your communities less
safe it's up to you to provide your own
security
see a white liberal doesn't need a gun
to do damage all he needs is a poisonous
idea and a little power
and they will destroy communities
quicker than 5 000 democrats moving to
huntsville
and they'll do it without a second
thought because they almost never have a
second thought
look at portland oregon but not for too
long the flash bangs will burn out your
retinas
according to john nolte of breitbart on
may 12
it recorded its 30th murder of the year
that's five times more than were
recorded during the same period in 2020.
this after last year's portland city
council cut the police budget by nearly
15 percent by the end of april they had
twice the number of shootings
and according to their hapless pathetic
mayor who had to flee his own condo
the city had an 85 percent decline in
foot and downtown foot traffic
unless you count the people running for
their lives most of the remaining foot
traffic is antifa and even when those
creeps are arrested the d8 declines
charges
like they're a collect call from hunter
biden cause and effect
this seems like the easiest thing to
learn but not a single democrat can
we knew that antifa or as joe biden
calls them an idea
being allowed to destroy a city would
destroy a city
we knew pushing the defunding of police
and branding them psychopaths would
weaken the forces and lead to emboldened
criminals
and minority victims they bear the brunt
of this you didn't have to be miss cleo
to see this coming
i wonder what the angry white male has
to say
oh the liberal elites
well look i gotta say i like them okay
yeah i got a lot of friends who i'd
described that way and
what they're good people good
conversationalists
they like wine books
good movie recommendations yeah i like
them
by the way i like babies and puppies too
but i wouldn't put them in charge of a
city
[Applause]
[Music]
he's wider than a pat boone family
reunion
let's check in on the angry blackmail
[Music]
hey so
i'm going to fund the police in your
city
the crime goes up
i mean i'm not eptomologists nothing but
if i want to keep the crime down in my
city i would support my police
department
it's not rocket surgery
nice day though
so democrats this has been today's
lesson in cause and effect
thank you for joining us on democrat
corner we hope that you remember
some of it biden 78 but you have no
excuse
welcome tonight's guest she used to
answer the president's questions
now she questions the president's
answers outnumbered co-host haley
mcinerney
he was elected to congress at 25 the
same age when i accomplished renting a
car
north carolina guy was in madison
cardboard
she's like a fence wiry useful and can
be seen outside of prisons
fox's contributor
and captain bus once got stuck in his
footprints
my massive sidekick and host have not
said on fox nation
pirates
all right i'm gonna go to you first
congressman only because it's weird
calling you congressman when you're like
half of cat's age i'm pretty sure i
don't have to be called congressman
until i'm 30. so you're you're in the
clear and cat you're only 21. i i
we check i like this guy he's a he's
like a better looking version of tom
brady
i was i was telling you earlier you know
when i used to be single i would
kill it in boston every time
don't go to tampa
[Laughter]
so what do you mean you're congressman
you deal with republicans all the time
you're a new member
what is it about cause and effect that
they don't understand you know what i
would say
when you start seeing what's going on in
congress and it's you can
say it's on both sides of the aisle but
it's almost entirely on the democratic
side of the aisle they are ruled by a
single person
in the embodied by nancy pelosi who
carries out her will with an iron fist
and it doesn't matter what these
democratic congressmen feel in their
hearts or if they think that wow you
know what
if we do defund the police in portland
then maybe our retinas will be burned
out with flash banks
yeah but the problem is is that they are
two more afraid of losing re-election
and nancy pelosi being against them than
they are of doing the right thing for
their constituents
and that is what is wrong with congress
kaylee do you agree
with this young tom brady i
i actually think that i even though they
know that we are right meaning we
non-liberals they would rather
let people suffer than be seen agreeing
with us it's like the trump effect
with the wuhan wuhan lab theory it's
like that was
he had the most plausible theory but you
couldn't agree with him because that was
trump
yeah exactly right and i do agree with
tom brady who we gladly welcome to tampa
and won a super bowl
that aside yeah the cause and effect
you're spot on okay you defund the
police
what do you think is gonna happen you
let violent criminals out of prison
during a pandemic
what do you think's gonna happen but
here is what amazes me
they take it a step further and they say
we have the answers for violent crime
it's that there's a pandemic and
everyone's locked inside
so therefore murders have gone up excuse
me how does that make any sense
even in mexico murders went down yes but
here in the united states
they're skyrocketing because of cause
and also who locked them inside
same democrats yes exactly how do you
like uh outnumbered so far you have a
good time i love it you haven't joined
us yet oh i
invited you weeks ago i'm picking the
right moment yes well we would welcome
you anytime we need you as a one lucky
guy
aren't i a lucky guy just being here yes
you are don't you think so tyrus
yup by the way where where did you film
one angry uh
blackmail in a secret location greg i
don't give away my
disclosure but let's just say the hotel
treats me nice
there's a problem with your monologue
and you know i always like your
monologues i very rarely ever dislike
your monologues but
i just feel like you're like a bad guy
in a movie who's trying to tell me you
forget the plan
just go shoot them you just don't get it
greg yes
you keep saying cause and effect all
they understand is cause
and they always want causes that don't
affect them
so it's very easy to sit in a very nice
place in a
cush apartment or condo or penthouse or
wherever you're
living talking about well of course let
them do this and do that because it's
not effective we don't need police
i've got a doorman and a security guard
i don't need police
let's get rid of them they're never
affected by what's going on in the world
and then
when it gets to the point where they can
see the fire burning from their
special viewing place where they sip
their wine and talk about days of all
that they never contributed in
that's when it's a problem and then
they're like hey let's refund the police
that doesn't help because most of the
officers have left town
right retired early and wouldn't come
back for double the wages
so they're oh we're going to fix it
again they don't here's another thing
they could learn from
republicans they don't know how to
change the narrative very good
right you can't just say oh new
information breaking news we just heard
that
there was a lab in wuhan that might have
done it this is crazy we never knew this
and then someone's going the one
republican on the panel was like excuse
me
we told you this too no no you're racist
sorry like they
they cannot fix problems because they're
just out of touch
right pelosi only cares about getting
her hair done and making sure her ice
cream freezer's full as long as she's
got ice cream and a good
good permanent yeah we good yeah what if
she gets hair in that ice cream
i'm you know between the dentures
falling out maybe
i don't know yes you know kat uh i
thought that for you
i thought the hangover was the best
example of cause and effect
the hangover you drink too much you pay
the price that's exactly like voting dem
for democrats
yeah might feel good but then hangover
was the perfect analogy to involve me
and because i am a raging alcoholic
and a horse tranquilizer addict
apparently
yeah don't forget the the computer
cleaner that you've been supposed to
coughing
yes yeah you've been huffing that
absolutely uh
look it was so exciting for a little bit
there these con
meaningful conversations we were having
about criminal justice reform
you know republicans were on board with
a lot of this stuff we're having these
important conversations and it
was exciting it got exciting and
sometimes when things get exciting
someone just has to go full
idiot yeah and that's what the left is
okay defund the police and
to deal with the overcrowding let's let
violent felons
with repeated violence in the acts of
violence in their past
out of jail so now we're seeing this and
everyone's saying well what happened
it's quite
obvious what happened there's a huge
difference between wanting criminal
justice reform
and wanting a ton of crime violent crime
on your streets because i do not like
violent crime
yeah i stand strongly against it and i'm
not gonna say where you live
because i i've i tweeted it earlier oh
thank you
there are hotels in in parts of new york
city
that are filled with felons yes and and
they're but
but we're told that we we say homeless
right because these people are homeless
but they're homeless because they were
released from rikers
which is a prison yeah so we can't say
these are
no one says the released felons until
they go out and they commit a crime on
the street
of manhattan and then you find out oh
this guy has been
arrested eight times in the past like
four months and he's just going back in
and out and in and out and that's
that's the solution it is a dis we've
reached the nadir
i don't know if it can get any low lower
than it is but it's very sad
very sad indeed and hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else